visual studio code a free and open
source program for editing code software
is just a collection of text files
organized in a precise way the s code
provides an integrated development
environment to help you edit analyze and
manage these files efficiently it's a
microsoft project that first appeared in
2015 as a lightweight cross-platform
code editor that ships a new update
every single month today it's the
world's most popular code editor
download it then use it to open a folder
that contains your application files
before you can write high quality code
you'll need to make the editor look cool
by clicking the settings icon to update
your syntax and icon themes next you'll
notice the file explorer contains all
the files in this directory open a file
and notice how the text inside is
colored that's because vs code analyzes
the symbols inside the file to perform
syntax highlighting it will
automatically detect problems in your
code if a variable is not used it
becomes a little more opaque a red
squiggly line appears if your code will
not compile hover over it for more
details it also creates an outline of
the code structure to quickly navigate
to the line of code that you're looking
for now as you start writing some code
in this file you'll notice a little box
pops up as you type professional
developers rarely type every character
instead they leverage vs code's
intellisense to autocomplete the code
that they were thinking about writing
when the right suggestion comes up hit
tab or enter to complete it you might
also right click on your code to find a
variety of options to analyze and
refactor it but almost anything you can
do with the mouse you can do faster with
the keyboard hit ctrl shift papa to
bring up the command palette from here
you can quickly access any vs code
command or any file in your project
let's use it to open up a terminal
session which brings up the command line
here at the bottom we can use it to run
commands in this project like git init
to enable source control or better yet
we can click on the source control icon
to run git commands with a visual
interface vs code is minimal by design
but as an open source javascript project
it's easily extendable from the
extensions panel you'll find a huge
number of packages that provide
specialized tooling for whatever
framework or language you're working
with most software projects work with
the cloud in some capacity the remote
button can connect your editor to a
remote github repository docker
container or cloud server and you can
even run vs code itself in the cloud to
access it from the browser on any
machine this has been vs code in 100
seconds hit the like button and
subscribe if you want to see more short
videos like this and if you really want
to maximize your productivity as a
developer i just released a brand new vs
code magic trix course that contains a
ton of productivity hacks for beginners
and advanced developers alike the first
10 videos are free so check it out on
fire ship io thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next one